Ich habe etwas für Sie und werde das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Erstmal benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten von Ihnen und dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden.
Falls Sie Fragen haben, suggen Sie bitte nicht mich zu unterbrechen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Franz Meister.
Könnten Sie bitte den Nach- und Vornamen langsam buchstabieren?
Franz mit F-R-A-N-Z Meister M-E-I-S-T-E-R
Wie alt sind Sie Herr Meister?
67, Herr Doktor.
Wie lange sind Sie hier?
Mein Gemüse-Statum ist 6.7.1958.
Wissen Sie wie groß Sie sind?
1,87 Meter.
Ihr Gewicht bitte?
74 Kilogramm wiege ich.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf, Herr Meister?
Ich bin Rentner, Herr Doktor. Ich bin Altmann.
Nein, Sie sind nur 67 Jahre alt. Was waren Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Rentner.
Was waren Sie?
Waren Sie, ja. Ich habe Machen verstanden. Es tut mir leid. Ich war Schreiner.
Schreiner, gut.
Haben Sie einen Hausarzt oder eine Hausärztin?
Ja. Frau Susanne. Susanne Genkner.
Susanne Genkner.
Ja.
Was für Sie heute sind, Herr Meister? Was ist Ihr Schwierigkeitswesen?
Herr Doktor, ich würde sagen, ich war seit vier Stunden hier.
Deswegen bin ich nicht glücklich.
Es tut mir leid zu hören, Herr Meister.
Ich habe Bauchschmerzen, Durchfall, aber seit vier Stunden warte ich hier.
Ist hier immer gleich?
Nein, nein. Es ist unterschiedlich, aber es tut mir leid zu hören, Herr Meister.
Jetzt haben Sie Bauchschmerzen und Durchfall, oder?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Bauchschmerzen und Durchfall.
Seit wann haben Sie das?
Seit zwei oder drei Monaten habe ich immer Bauchschmerzen und Durchfall.
Wo genau tut es Ihnen weh?
Unterbau.
Links oder rechts?
Ja, ganzbau und unterbau. Mitte, ganzbau. Manchmal rechts, manchmal links, aber ganzbau, fühle ich.
Zuerst hatte ich ein oder zweimal Durchfall, aber seit einer Woche habe ich fünf oder sechs Mal Durchfall.
Seit einer Woche.
Meine Bauchschmerzen sind verschlimmert.
Während der Zeit.
Verschlimmert.
Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Durchstechen, drücken.
Das ist wie Krampf.
Krampf, ja.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft da oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Dauerhaft.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen von eins bis zehn auf einer Skala, wobei zehn am stärksten ist?
Ja, das ist, das kann ich nicht genau sagen, aber das ist nicht sehr schlimm, ich kann sagen.
Aber immer da und das stört mir, stört mich vielleicht fünf oder sechs, weiß ich nicht, aber.
Fünf oder sechs.
Zuerst, es war zwei oder drei.
Gibt es irgendwelche Auslöser dafür?
Haben Sie es bemerkt? Zum Beispiel Fettiges Essen, bestimmte Ernährungsmittel?
Nein, nein, ich habe ständig Bauchschmerzen.
Gibt es irgendetwas, das die Schmerzen schlimmer oder besser macht?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, Herr Doktor.
Sind die Schmerzen und Durchfall allmählich oder plötzlich aufgetreten?
Langsam aufgetreten. Langsam.
Als ich gesagt habe, es war zwei oder drei, in der letzten Woche, das ist fünf oder sechs.
Wie sah Ihr Stuhl aus?
Es ist wässrig, wie Wasser.
Welche Farbe hat Ihr Stuhl?
Ja, das ist wie Wasser, ich kann sagen. Manchmal weiß, manchmal wie Glanz.
Haben Sie Blut im Stuhl bemerkt?
Ja, manchmal ist es schwarz geworden.
Aber nicht ganz genau rot, aber dunkel rot. Manchmal schwarz. Ich habe das nicht verstanden.
Haben Sie frische Blut bemerkt?
Nicht frisch, aber dunkel rot habe ich gesehen.
Wie viele Mal haben Sie es bemerkt?
In Nesterdorf, oder?
Ja.
Ja, immer fünf. Manchmal zehn Mal.
Wann war das letzte Mal?
Gestern.
Haben Sie Fieber? Fühlen Sie sich fieberlich?
Ja, ich fühle mich fieberlich. Nicht genau Fieber, aber ich habe gemessen, dass meine Fieber war. Meine Körpertemperatur war 37,5 heute Morgen.
Wo haben Sie es gemessen?
Ja, Axel, so.
Gibt es jemanden in Ihrer Umgebung, der ähnliche Beschwerden hat?
Nein, nein, Herr Doktor. Ich lebe mit meiner Frau. Sie ist das genug.
Haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente genommen?
Nein, nein.
Haben Sie volle Gefühle, Sod brennen, Sauerstoff oder Blechungen?
Manchmal habe ich Blechungen, aber ich habe kein Sod brennen, oder andere.
Die anderen nicht.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Herzstolpen?
Ja, ich habe Herzstolpen. Ich habe eine Herzrhythmusstörung seit einem Jahr.
Seit einem Jahr?
Ja.
Wurde bei Ihnen eine Festdiagnose gesteht?
Die Kardiologie hat mir gesagt, dass ich Herzrhythmusstörung habe.
Dagegen nehme ich Methoprolol regelmäßig.
In welcher Dosis?
50 mg.
Wie oft nehmen Sie?
Einmal pro Tag, morgens.
Verstehe.
Haben Sie Hautverfarbung bemerkt? Blasse Haut?
Ja, meine Frau hat mir gesagt, dass ich krank aussehe.
Ein bisschen Blasse Haut.
Verstehe.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß, Schuttelfrost, Herr Meister?
Nachschweiß habe ich, aber Schuttelfrost habe ich nicht.
Jeden Nacht muss ich meine Kleidung wechseln.
Verstehe. Ist Ihnen üben?
Nein, habe ich keine Übung.
Mussten Sie sich übergeben?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Manchmal, aber nicht oft.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Herr Meister?
Mein Appetit ist nicht gut, Herr Doktor. Ich kann kaum essen.
Warum essen Sie nicht?
Ich weiß nicht, Herr Doktor.
Seit wann haben Sie das?
Seit ungefähr zwei oder drei Monaten habe ich kaum Appetit und habe 5 Kilo abgenommen.
In welchem Zeitraum haben Sie 5 Kilo abgenommen?
In drei Monaten.
Haben Sie das Gefühl, dass Sie Ihr Stuhl nicht entleeren können?
Nein, ich habe Durchfall und kann entleeren.
Verstehe.
Wie ist Ihr Wasserlassen?
Ja, es ist auch schlimm, Herr Doktor.
Ich lasse Wasser jeden Tag zehnmal oder bei zehnmal.
Das ist sehr oft.
Seit wann haben Sie das?
Ich leide an Vorherdrüse.
Vergrößert seit fünf Jahren.
Seit fünf Jahren.
Nehmen Sie dagegen Medikamente?
Ja, ich nehme Antiprostat-Tablet.
Welche Dosis?
Weiß ich nicht.
Eine Malprota.
Können Sie gut schlafen?
Ja, normalerweise schlafe ich gut, aber mindestens dreimal wache ich auch wegen dem Wasserlassen.
Haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen außer Herzrhythmusstörungen und Vorherdrüsenvergrößerung?
Ja, ich leide an Bluthochdruck seit fünf Jahren.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ich nehme Norvask-Tablet.
Zehn Milligramm einmal morgens.
Haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich leide an Reisdarm-Zyndrom seit zehn Jahren.
Seit zehn Jahren.
Hatten Sie das schon einmal?
Reisdarm-Zyndrom war nicht gleich wie das.
Früher hatte ich manchmal Verstopfung, manchmal Durchfall.
Aber in den letzten drei Monaten habe ich immer Durchfall.
Das ist ganz anders, oder?
Nicht ganz. Bauchschmerzen ist wie, aber nicht gleich.
Verstehe. Was nehmen Sie gegen Reisdarm-Zyndrom?
Ja, ich trinke Kräuter-Tea.
Haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Letztes Jahr hatte ich fünfmal Handweginfektion gehabt.
Und ich habe sehr oft Antibiotika eingenommen.
Haben Sie Zuckerkrankheit?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, vor drei Jahren habe ich die Blase entfällt.
Vor drei Jahren.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein, habe ich keine Allergien.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Gelegen.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Ja, jeden Abend trinke ich zwei Blase Bier.
Teilisch.
Bier ist nur Alkohol.
Seit wann trinken Sie Alkohol?
Seit 40 Jahren vielleicht.
Das ist so viel.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche nicht.
Haben Sie vorher geraucht?
Nein.
Nehmen Sie die folgende Frage nicht persönlich.
Aus medizinischen Gründen fragen wir immer.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein, nein, Herr Doktor, nein.
Gut. Sie sind verheiratet?
Ja.
Nehmen Sie mit Ihrer Ehepraus zusammen?
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Gott sei Dank, ja.
Gut.
Gibt es irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Meine Mutter ist ganz gesund.
Sie ist 85.
Gut zu hören. Ich freue mich.
Ihr Vater?
Mein Vater ist leider an Darmkrebs gestorben.
Gut zu hören. Wie alt war er?
Vor 30 Jahren. Er war ungefähr 60.
Mein sehr beileid, Herr Meister.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder.
Hat er chronische Erkrankungen?
Nein, ich weiß nicht. Wir sind nicht eng.
Gut. Manchmal könnte es passieren.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, denke ich. Aber was meinen Sie damit?
Gegen Kinderkrankheit und Covid-19?
Ja, denke ich schon.
Bisher wurde bei Ihnen eine Koloskopie durchgeführt.
Nein, vor zehn Jahren vielleicht.
Erst mal Reisdarm-Syndrom.
Wurde bei Ihnen eine Festdiagnose gestellt?
Ja, mein Hausarzt hat mir gesagt, dass ich Reisdarm-Syndrom habe.
Ich weiß, außer Reisdarm-Syndrom.
Polyp oder noch was anderes.
Vor zehn Jahren.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ich glaube gerne.
Wie ernähren Sie, Herr Meister?
Vielleicht reich essen oder Gemüse reich essen.
Ich esse alles.
Morgen esse ich Brötchen mit Marmelade.
Mittags esse ich Kartoffelsalat.
Manchmal mit verschiedenen Arten.
Meinerseits habe ich alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen, Herr Meister?
Ja, ich möchte noch etwas hinzufügen.
Machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen, Herr Meister.
Es ist zu früh, etwas Genaues zu sagen.
Jetzt werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschauen.
Danach werde ich Labour-Untersuchungen und operative Diagnostikmaßnahmen durchschauen.
Dann können wir entscheiden.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie Sie das machen.
Es ist zu früh, etwas Genaues zu sagen, Herr Meister.
Mit den Ergebnissen können wir mehr überspringen.
Muss ich hier bleiben oder?
Ja, natürlich. Jetzt werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschauen.
Deswegen sollen Sie hier warten.
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Gerne.
Guten Tag, Frau Oberersten.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen, den ich in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Hätten Sie kurz Zeit?
Es handelt sich um Franz Meister, ein 67-jähriger Patient, geboren am 6.7.1978.
Er ist 1,87 Meter groß und 740 Kilogramm schwer.
Er stellt sich bei uns vor aufgrund, dass seit 2-3 Monaten
bestehende krampfartige Unterbauchschmerzen ohne Ausstrahlung
als Begleitsymptomen liegen seit einer Woche 5-6 Mal mit wasrigem Diarrhea.
Er hatte diese Beschwerden zum ersten Mal.
Aber vor 10 Jahren wurde bei ihm das Reisdarm-Syndrom festgestellt.
Damals hatte er Verstopfung und Diarrhea.
Aber diese Beschwerden sind erstmals.
Er berichtete, diese Beschwerden seien allmählich aufgetreten.
Darüber hinaus klagte er über Meteorismus, Palau.
Die Frage nach Reflü wurden verneint.
In der vegetative Anamnese sind folgende bekannt.
Fieber 37,5 Grad.
Nachtschweiß, Insomni, seit 3 Monaten.
Insomni wegen Polyakisüri.
Vertigo, Inapetens, seit 3 Monaten.
Gewichtabnahme, seit 3 Monaten.
Innerhalb von 3 Monaten 5 kg.
Und rote Stürme.
Er berichtete, dass er dunkelrote Blut im Körper hatte.
Er leidet seit einem Jahr an Herzrhythmus-Störungen.
Dagegen nimmt er 50 mg Metoprolol einmal täglich ein.
Seit 5 Jahren hat er eine Prostatehyperplasie.
Dagegen nimmt er Antiprostat einmal täglich ein.
Die Dosis ist nicht erinnerlich.
Seit 5 Jahren leidet er an Arteriella-Hypertonie.
Dagegen nimmt er Norvask Tablet 10 mg ein.
Seit 10 Jahren leidet er an den Reisdarmzentrum.
Dagegen trinkt er Kreutat.
Letztes Jahr hatte er 5 Mal eine Handwerkinfektion.
Bei ihm wurde vor 30 Jahren eine Sistektomie durchgeführt.
Es sind keine Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten bekannt.
Er ist nicht Raucher.
Er trinkt seit 40 Jahren 2 Gläser Bier täglich.
Dagegen würde er verneint.
Er ist verheiratet.
Er lebt mit seiner Frau zusammen.
Er hat 2 gesunde Kinder.
In der Familienanamnese fand er sich.
Der Vater ist mit 60 Jahren an Kolankarsinom verstoben.
Er hat einen Bruder, aber keinen Kontakt mit ihm.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Meine Verdachtstheorose lautet auf Kolankarsinom.
Dafür schiebe ich Gewichtabnahme.
Seit 3 Monaten bestehende Bauchschmerzen.
In der Familienanamnese hat der Vater Kolankarsinom.
Er ist an Kolankarsinom verstoben.
Die Differenzialdiagnostik ist die Vertikulitis.
Magenkarsinom und Hemorrhoid.
In der Diagnostik würde ich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschauen.
Zunächst würde ich die vitalen Parameter erfassen.
Danach würde ich den Patienten inspezieren, palpieren und auskultieren.
Bei Verdacht auf Kolankarsinom ist die Palpation wegweisend.
Bei der Palpation achte ich auf Druckschmerzen, Abbespannung.
In diesem Fall würde ich eine digitale, rektale Untersuchung durchschauen.
Bei der digitale, rektale Untersuchung können wir den Tumor erkennen.
Der Tumor bei der Untersuchung ist tatsprechend.
Zu weiteren Diagnostik würde ich Laborkuntersuchungen durchschauen.
Ich überprüfe das Blutbild ALT, ALT, AST, die Entzündungswerte, CEA und CA9.
Zu weiteren Abklärungen würde ich die operative Diagnostik durchschauen.
Um eine Laborknotenvergrößerung oder mögliche Organomegalie auszuschließen,
würde ich die Sonographie des Abdomens durchschauen.
Bei Verdacht auf Kolankarsinom ist die Koloskopie der Goldstandard.
Ich würde unbedingt eine Koloskopie durchschauen.
Bei der Koloskopie können wir den Tumor erkennen.
Ich würde auch eine Therapie durchführen.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtstheorose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Ich würde ein chirurgisches Konzil durchführen, um die Therapie zu optimieren.
Ich verstehe. Gibt es eine Riesengenau-Faktoren für Kolonkarsinom?
Der Vater leidet seit zehn Jahren an der Reissdarm-Syndrom.
Der Vater leidet seit sechs Jahren an der Reissdarm-Syndrom.
Er trinkt seit 40 Jahren zwei Gläser Bier.
Das kann als Risiko-Faktoren bezahlt werden.
Wie sieht der klinische Zustand des Patienten aus?
Leider kann ich bisher keine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Er sieht blass aus und kann die Fragen antworten.
Aber er hat Diarrhea und seit drei Monaten eine Woche.
Eine Woche sind die Bekämpfung verschlimmert.
Nach der körperlichen Untersuchung kann ich genauer entscheiden.
Hat der Patient jetzt eine Verstoffung?
Seit drei Monaten leidet er an Diarrhea.
Seit einer Woche sind die Bekämpfungen verschlimmert.
Er geht zur Toilette fünf- bis sechsmal.
Möchten Sie für diesen Patienten eine Koloskopie durchführen?
Aber in seiner Differentialdiagnose gibt es auch Divertiglitz.
Bei Akutemkontrollen warte ich zuerst die Ergebnisse der Entzündungswerte.
Hat der Patient Fieber?
Er hat Fieber im Februar.
Und Sie warten für eine Koloskopie?
Zuerst werden die Labultezugungen durchführt.
Dann werden die Ultraschall des Abdomens durchführt.
Wenn die Befunde unglä sind, werden die CT des Abdomens veranlasst.
Wenn wir die Divertiglitz erkennen, können wir keine Koloskopie durchführen.
Okay, wir können die Koloskopie durchführen.
Die Koloskopie ist eine bildgebende Methode.
Mit der können wir Darm- und Massdarm bis 12 Fingerdarm beurteilen.
Es enthält einen Schlauch mit einer Kamera und einer Lichtquelle.
Wir führen den Schlauch durch den Aft ein.
Das ist nicht nur eine diagnostische Maßnahme, sondern auch eine therapeutische.
Gleichzeitig können wir eine Gewebeprobe entnehmen und eine Polyp entfernen.
Vor der Untersuchung sollte der Patient vorbereitet werden.
Das ist eine schmerzhafte Untersuchung. Deswegen verabreichen wir örtliche Betäubung.
Nach der Untersuchung braucht der Patient eine begleitende Person.
Hat der Patient Hematurkeza oder Hematopäse?
Er hat nicht eine Melanose.
Bei der Melanose war es eher ein T-Shirt.
Aber er sagte, es sei dunkel.
Es könnte Hematopäse sein.
Hat der Patient Hematopäse?
Er hat keine Hematopäse.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Können Sie die Patienten zusammenfassen?
Ich berichte über Herrn Franz Meister.
Er ist 1,87 Meter groß.
Der Patient ist heute bei uns.
Er hat seit 3 Monaten eine krankartige, persistierende,
unterbauchschmerzen und wässerigen Diary.
Er kann 5-6 Mal pro Tag vorgehen.
Außerdem klagt der Patient über Inapathens.
Fibre bis 37,5 Grad.
Er hat nächtliche Hyperhydrose und Insomni,
Palor und Melena.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 5 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala bewertet.
Darüber hinaus erwähnte der Patient das Eruntervertigo Polyery.
An der Vorerkrankung gab er das
Reisdamm-Syndrom seit 10 Jahren,
Arteriellhypertronik seit 5 Jahren,
Ersrhythmusstörung seit einem Jahr,
Prostathyperkulose seit 5 Jahren.
Er nimmt regelmäßig 50 mg Metrocronöl morgens,
10 mg Norvaks morgens,
und 1 Pro Tag Antiprostat Tablet.
Der Patient fügt den Hinzu, dass er letzte Jahr 5 Mal
an Hanweckinfektion geritten hat.
Der Patient hat gesagt, dass er Hanweckinfektion gehabt hat.
Wir wissen nicht ob es eine Sistetis oder Nephritis ist.
Wir haben kaum Informationen über Hanweckinfektion.
Es gibt sehr wahrscheinlich eine Sistetis.
Vor 30 Jahren wurde er wegen
der Galenblase-Krankheit operiert.
Er ist vollständig genügt.
Er wurde an Allergien, Unverträglichkeit und Reiseanamnesen vermeint.
Er ist nicht traurig.
Er trinkt 2 Gläser pro Tag.
Seit 40 Jahren wurde er an Drogenkonsum vermeint.
Er hatte gesagt, dass seine Mutter gesund war.
Sein Vater ist vor 30 Jahren gestorben.
Er hat einen Dammkarsinom gestorben.
Er hat ein Bruder, er ist rennt und hat zwei Kinder und lebt mit ihrer Frau.
Die Anamnestischen angaben am ersten Tag auf einen Kolonkarsinom hin.
Die Differenzialdiagnostik kam an.
Der Karsinoid-Syndrom Divertkulitis Morbus Crohn Colitis Ulcerosa in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich den Patienten zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Ich achte darauf, ob es eine Druckdollens oder Abwehrspannung gibt.
Ich werde Blut abnehmen.
Ich werde ein großes Blutbild aus der SRP, BSG und möglichen entzündeten Darmerkrankungen ausschließen.
Ich werde die Nierenwerte, die Lebewerte, die LDH, die ALP, die CA19, die BND-9 und die CA125 bestimmen.
Ich werde eine Abdomen-Sonographie durchführen, um mögliche Abdomenkrankheiten oder Zumore und Acid auszuschließen.
Ich werde eine Koloskopie durchführen, um mögliche Kolonkarsinom-Syndroms oder Divertkulitis oder Blut auszuschließen.
Ich werde den Patienten stationär aufnehmen, um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestimmen.
Gastroenterologisches und Chirurgisches Konzils sind sinnvoll, um eine genaue Diagnose zu bestätigen und die Behandlung zu optimieren.
Welche Therapien und Optionen haben Sie?
Die Therapien und Optionen sind die die Diagnose. Wenn wir einen Kolonkarsinom bestellen, dann werden wir während der Koloskopie eine Gewerbeprobe machen.
Ich werde die Chirurgisches Konzils durchführen.
Bevor ich die Chirurgisches Konzils durchführen werde, werde ich die Chirurgisches Konzils durchführen.
Welche Maßnahmen?
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall eine CT des Abdomens und eine PET-CT durchführen, wenn wir einen Kolonkarsinom feststellen, um eine mögliche Metastase und ein Stadion zu bestimmen.
Okay, würde eine Gastroskopie oder Kolonoskopie durchgeführt?
Wir haben keine Informationen über Koloskopie oder Endoskopie. Bei der Körperwanderung ist die Frage wieder.
Der Patient hat gesagt, dass es eine Koloskopie für die Geschichte ist, aber vor zehn Jahren?
Vor zehn Jahren hat ein Mann eine Koloskopie durchgeführt.
Aber es gibt keine Befunde?
Können Sie uns eine PET-CT aufklaren?
Ja, PET-CT ist eine Bildgebende verfahren mit Hilfe der FDG 18.
Das ist ein Typ von Glukos, der die Tumorzellen bestimmen kann, ob es eine Metastase gibt.
Wenn es eine Metastase gibt, können wir eine Metastase mit Hilfe der PET-CT bestimmen.
Muss der Patient eine Vorbereitung machen?
Ja, bevor diese Vorbereitung, muss der Patient eine besondere Art Glukos einnehmen.
Ich habe keine Informationen über PET-CT. Ich werde die PET-CT recherchieren.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine chronische Darmentzündung haben. Welche Symptome haben Sie?
Der Patient leidet unter permanentem Diarrhea und Bauchschmerzen.
Er hat fünf Kilo abgenommen und krampfartige Bauchschmerzen.
Diese Beschwerden sprechen für eine chronische entzündliche Darmerkrankung.
Denken Sie, dass der Patient unter Melena leidet?
Das ist ein Befund für Kolitis ulcerosa.
Diese Symptome sprechen für chronische entzündliche Darmerkrankungen.
Denken Sie, dass der Patient unter Melena leidet?
Das kann auch sein. Der Patient leidet unter Melena.
Deswegen wird eine Gastroesophagodäroskopie sinnvoll.
Gibt es eine Hinweise auf Metastas?
Die Gewichtabnahme ist ein Signal für Metastas.
Der Patient leidet unter keinem Schmerz in der anderen Körperregion.
Deswegen können wir nicht genau darüber denken.
Hat der Patient unter Lungenmetastas oder Knochen Schmerzen?
Wie ist der Allgemeinszustand der Patient?
Ich habe gehört, dass der Patient leidet an langer Wartenseite.
Der Patient leidet seitlich und örtlich.
Er hat alle Fragen ganz genau antwortet.
Deswegen können wir sagen, der Allgemeinszustand ist gut.
Der Patient sieht ein bisschen blass aus.
Der Patient hat eine Verhidratation.
Er hat auch Vertigo?
Ja, er hat Vertigo.
Deswegen müssen wir den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Wir müssen den Patienten genügend Flüssigkeit verbreiten.
Vielen Dank, Frau Wehrsinn.
Vielen Dank.
Guten Abend, Frau Wehrsinn.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen den Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, gerne.
Es handelt sich um Herrn Franz Meister.
Er ist 67 Jahre alt, 1,87 Meter groß und 54 Kilogramm schwer.
Er ist 54 Kilogramm schwer.
Ist das richtig oder falsch?
Ich bin nicht sicher.
75 Kilogramm oder?
Ich habe hier geschrieben, ich bin nicht sicher.
Wir können wiederholen.
Der Patient steht heute bei uns.
Seit 2-3 Monaten ist er pro Grad im Hypogastrium.
Er hat keine Medikamente angenommen.
Der Patient hat keine Ärzte.
Er hat keine Ärzte.
Er hat keine Medikamente angenommen.
Der Patient hat wegen dieser Beschwerden nicht bei einem Arzt gewesen.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 5 bis 6 Fond auf eine Schmerzskala bewertet.
Der Patient berichtet über eine Gewichtabnahme von 5 Kilogramm innerhalb von 3 Monaten.
Die Beschwerden gehen mit Metaurythmus und Palo einher.
Die Vegetative Anamnese sind folgendes ergeben.
Pyrexie, Inapetens, Insomnie, Nachschweiß, Nitri und Vertigo.
Anführerkrankungen nach der NAM-PR seit 5 Jahren.
Prostatehyperplasie.
Seit 5 Jahren bestehende arterielle Hypertonie.
Seit 10 Jahren bestehende Reissdarm-Syndrome.
Er hatte viele Mal Pharmaekinfektionen wie Zistitis.
Vor 3 Jahren wurde bei ihm eine Cholocystektomie durchgeführt.
Vor 10 Jahren wurde bei ihm eine Zistektomie durchgeführt.
Im Besuch auf Medikation nimmt er Metaprolol 50 mg einmal täglich,
Antiprostat Tablette einmal, aber der Name die Dosierung und sollte geklaut werden.
Außerdem nimmt er Norvastablet 10 mg ein und sie benutzt eine Kräuter wegen Pharmaekinfektionen.
Allergische Geschichte ist unauffällig.
Er ist kein Raucher.
Er trinkt gelegentlich, er hat Gelegentlichkeit.
Er hat Gelegentlichkeit.
Er trinkt gelegentlich.
Gelegentlich. Aber er trinkt zwei Glaser pro Tag.
Im Besuch auf Familienanamnese teilt er mit, dass die Mutter gesund ist.
Der Vater ist an Kolonkarsinom mit 60 Jahren verstorben.
Er ist von ständig geimpft.
Raiese anamnese ist unauffällig.
Er ist Rentner, aber früher als Schreiner gearbeitet.
Der Patient ist verheiratet und hat zwei Kinder.
Die Kinder sind gesund.
Sie wohnen mit der Familie.
Er trinkt keinen Sport.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf Kolonkarsinom aus.
Da der Patient dafür typische Symptome aufweist,
ist der Patient leider untergewischt.
Er hat einen Namen, eine Diore, eine Bauchschmerzen.
Nachschweiz und Melena.
Diese beiden sprechen für Kolonkarsinom.
Als Differenzierdiagnose kommen auch Divertikulitis, Morbus Crohn und Magenkarsinom in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst den Patienten
und die beiden Körperliche Unterzüge beachten.
Ich werde darauf achten, ob er abweichende Schmerzen und Druckschmerzen vorliegen.
Außerdem würde ich Lungen, Herz und Abdomen auskürzen, palpieren und perkutieren.
Nach der Körperlichen Unterzüge wäre die Laborunterzüge ein Symbol, um die Diagnose zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild, BSG, CRP, Nierenwerte, Lebewerte, Entzündungsparameter und Tumormarker bestimmen lassen.
Dann würde ich den Patienten die Zonographie des Abdomens durchführen und möglicherweise die Abdomenpathologie ausdrücken.
Dabei würde ich das Symbol eine Koloskopie durchführen, wenn es etwas Auffälliges gibt.
Wenn es nötig ist, würde ich den Patienten die Zonographie des Abdomens durchführen.
Dann würde ich die Diagnose durchführen, wenn es nötig ist, um die Abdomenpathologie ausdrücken.
Sollte sich meine Diagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Aber abhängig vom Tumor werde ich den Patienten einen Benutzung vorlegen und eine Physikeseforschung verabreichen.
Dann würde ich den Patienten eine gastroenterologische Konzilordnung und meine Therapie optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, würde ich mit dem Geplanten unterzuchen und fortfahren.
Was ist mit Unterbauchschmerzen?
Ich habe vielleicht falsch gesagt. Der Patient hat Unterbauchschmerzen, Hypogastikschmerzen, nicht Epigastik.
Hat der Patient zwei oder einmal Operationen gehabt?
Der Patient hat zwei Operationen gehabt. Eine Cholesthektomie und eine Zistektomie.
Eine Zistektomie?
Nein, eine Cholesthektomie, nicht eine Zistektomie.
Nicht Zistektomie, ja, ich denke.
Und hat der Patient Schwester?
Der Patient hat Bruder, eine Bruder, ein Bruder.
Ist er ...
Ich denke, kein Kontakt.
Ja, kein Kontakt.
Und der Patient hat Brexie oder?
Ja, der Patient hat Brexie.
Wie?
Ja, das Brexie hat 37,5 gemessen mit Achselöle.
Das ist Brexie, wie Sie sagen?
Nein, nicht Brexie. Das ist Superbrillbrexie.
Okay. Und möchten Sie diese Patienten digitale Untersuchungen durchführen? Oder?
Ja, es ist eine mögliche Untersuchungmethode.
Ja, digital rechte Untersuchungen.
Meinen Sie digital rechte Untersuchungen?
Ja.
Digital rechte Untersuchungen sind wichtig, um die möglichen Diagnosen zu bestätigen.
Ja, ich werde den Patienten auch digital rechte Untersuchungen machen.
Und hat der Patient nur einmal Melena gehabt?
Ich bin nicht sicher.
Ja.
Ich denke, der Patient hat gesagt, zehnmal vielleicht.
Ich habe nicht gehört.
Ja.
Okay.
Ich habe viele gehört.
Ja, nicht falsch, aber ... ja.
Okay. Welche Untersuchungen möchten Sie aufklären?
Wenn Sie möchten, dann kläre ich die Abdomenzonographie.
Okay. Und wie warten Sie?
Wie warten Sie auf die Abdomenzonographie für diese Patienten?
Ja, wir warten auf die Abdomenzonographie.
Wir warten auf die Abdomenzonographie,
die wir jetzt auch haben.
Aber wir warten auf die Abdomenzonographie.
Ja, wir können eine Tumor-Sagung machen.
Und wie können wir die abdomen Sonographie erklären?
Ich würde gerne Ihnen die abdomen Sonographie erklären.
Die abdomen Sonographie ist eine strahlensfreie Untersuchung.
Diese Untersuchung ist schmerzlos und es sind keine Nadeln benötigt.
Die Mitglieder der Untersuchung tragen eine Gelbe auf den Betroffenenbereich.
Die Bilder der Gewebe werden auf einem Monitor dargestellt.
Es gibt keine Vorbereitung für die Untersuchungen.
Nach der Untersuchung sollte der Patient seine Altar-Vigemund fortsetzen.
Mit dieser Untersuchung können wir die Organe, zum Beispiel Leber, Milz, Bauchspalz, Dürüze beurteilen.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die Erkrankungen wie Tumore, Tumorestein, Entzündungen und andere Veränderungen frühzeitig zu erkennen.
In manchen Fällen kann stattdessen eine andere Untersuchung, wie zum Beispiel das St. des Abdomens, durchgeführt werden.
Aber abhängig vom Krankenbilder. Ich bin fertig.